this way
oh was it was the wrong one
all right yeah
ah perfect
um
accomplish
Ed
okay
all right well I mean normally I don't
have to do anything
[Music]
physically intelligence system needed
yeah
no no I don't know
good morning
before that stairs yeah
the worst style you walk in with a piece
of chalk and you have a Blackboard
is that charging or display
s
yes
uh what
oh all right
put it on a memory stick okay fine fine
okay all right here by we call the five
minute break okay
okay
it's fresh outside
yourself
um oh
yeah yeah I I I I I I I really just
don't know normally I just put it in and
it either works
yeah
thank you thank you
foreign
[Music]
so much
yes it works okay okay pause
all right everybody back inside
[Applause]
okay so after the break for technical
difficulties it's a great pleasure to
introduce
yeah all right uh thank you
all right thanks so um
yeah there are there are uh three three
separate things that I'm that I'm
nervous about right now and uh giving
giving giving this talk uh one is one is
that uh you know that my my my laptop
didn't work the second is that I've this
afternoon of all times I've lost my
voice and I'm you know speaking rasply
and the third is that uh uh if the um uh
uh discriminator model that Dan Klein
presented a couple hours ago uh works as
well as it seems to then you might not
need watermarking at all okay
um but you know but then again you might
so
um so uh so so I'll tell you about you
know how this works uh it's been you
know this is something that's been
talked about for for a year and you know
that I've sort of been pushing on you
know so far I've not managed to get this
successfully deployed uh uh anywhere but
you know the idea is there and I hope
that it will be useful at some point in
the future of language models so
um uh you know there was a whole uh
episode of South Park a few months ago
about who who saw it about about chat
GPT where you know more and more of the
students at South Park Elementary start
using relying on chat GPT to you know
both you know do all of their homework
you know write messages to their
boyfriends or girlfriends the teachers
start using chat GPT to grade the
homework and eventually they have to
bring a wizard into the school that's
that guy and he has a detection tool
which is a falcon on his shoulder that
flies around and when it whenever it
sees that something came from GPT it
cause
so you know that this guy I guess that's
basically been my job at open AI
so
um
okay so let me let me start with what is
the attribution problem okay so you know
you've all seen these these headlines
right and I uh uh it's very weird to
work on something where there's you know
uh you just turn to the news and you
know every day or two there are
headlines about the problem that you're
you know supposedly trying to solve uh
um but uh you know uh We've now had a
semester where uh
um we know that chat GPT was massively
used for you know uh doing homework you
know the total usage of uh uh chat GPT
dropped appreciably at the beginning of
the summer okay if um
if it if it if it rises back up you know
and if in a few weeks then you know we
will know for sure uh what was what was
going on with that
um but you know you can you can also
worry about
um uh you know the use you know the the
you know the uh the use of uh uh uh llms
for generating massive amounts of
propaganda you know spamming every uh
comment section with Pro Putin talking
points or uh uh impersonating someone
you know generating spam emails right
and and actually for me I think the the
beginning of this was when I uh started
uh you know this this sort of sabbatical
uh to work at open AI a year ago and you
know I'm a Quantum Computing theorist uh
which is you know a very weird kind of
person to be to be thinking about you
know the these these things I mean you
know now now now now who isn't thinking
about it now you know
Umesh is organizing this very Workshop
okay but uh you know I didn't uh uh
really know what uh uh uh what I should
work on but you know in the meantime my
my blog was just being attacked by these
really really dedicated trolls you know
just just just putting you know I I
guess I should be flattered putting an
unbelievable amount of effort into you
know how to just most upset me how to
most uh uh you know pretend to be people
who I knew and this and that and you
know making me sort of not able to trust
anything and I had this this moment that
uh like oh my God like as bad as this is
now I'll imagine if someone can use an
llm to generate as much of this stuff as
they want and since then I have gotten
uh uh uh you know regularly comments on
my blog uh you know attacking me or
things like that that uh seem very very
clearly generated by llms
um you know that that's even without
watermarking or anything they're just
written in that characteristic way uh
um and so so the Insight here is that
you know for almost okay if we you know
whoa whoa wolf that aside for now the uh
you know uh deceptively aligned super AI
of the future that you know wants to uh
uh uh uh uh kill us all or enslave us
all or whatever if we think about the
you know near-term misuses of uh uh a
generative AI uh pretty much all of them
involve con you know in one way or
another concealing that a language model
was involved and you know if only we
could make it harder to conceal the
involvement of the AI we would sort of
uh fight all of these different
categories of misuse simultaneously
uh and there's even a separate reason
from that for caring about this
attribution problem uh namely you know
the internet is going to get
increasingly filled with you know the
outputs of of generative Ai and that is
also you know the source of the training
data okay and so uh training data you
know if you don't do anything else we'll
get increasingly polluted by you know
llm output and you'll be you know biting
your own tail okay you'll be you know
training on your own output which you
might worry gets you know further and
further from the the sort of you know
human output that you're supposed to be
emulating uh so you know for for this
purpose also you would love to be able
to identify what was AI generated and
what was not
um and uh uh well maybe we'll talk about
it later but but a few weeks ago there
was actually a White House commitment uh
uh uh between uh uh some of the major AI
companies to do a bunch of uh uh uh
things for AI safety and one of those
was was a water marking although in the
fine print it says watermarking for
audio visual content uh so uh you know
whether you know what what is going to
happen with text that remains a question
uh but uh but but in any case uh there
is now you know an agreement in
principle that you know making AI output
identifiable as such is good and uh you
know uh a Biden actually explicitly
mentioned in a speech uh Watermark it
you know whether or not he uh you know
could Define it you know he he he
believes that it is good so so
um
uh so so okay so what are what are the
uh proposed solutions to to the uh you
know this this attribution problem
um you know I mean I mean you know you
could say the most obvious thing to do
right you know we have now had a a
semester with uh you know Untold numbers
of assignments that were turned in or
even job applications submitted that
contain if you read them stuff like as a
large language model trained by open AI
right so you know if if people are not
going to go to even the minimal effort
to take to take that stuff out then you
don't need to do any watermarking or
anything else right even without that
stuff you know as I mentioned before
sometimes you can you can sort of tell
by by eyeballing it uh uh whether
something is likely to have come from an
llm
um uh you know now now with many kinds
of content you know people are now I'm
talking about just attaching metadata to
the end of it right or or uh you know
putting metadata in the file that says
where it came from uh you know that
makes some sense for you know images for
videos you know where you know you might
have to know something in order to
remove the metadata I mean certainly it
makes sense if the goal of the metadata
is to prove that it you know that the
thing you generated did come from this
source and then you can put a digital
signature for example uh into your file
but you know if your goal is to prove
like I wrote this you know this was not
generated by an llm right then uh you
know it's uh uh you know sort of
metadata doesn't really solve that
problem because you know it could be
trivially taken out right and that's all
the more so for text or you know imagine
that uh I I I actually uh um you know
when I I showed uh you know so my my my
my kids you know love using GPT uh but
uh uh you know I I uh uh uh you know in
the the playground mode for example and
I I explained to my my six-year-old son
you know what is uh uh the pro
watermarking you know what's the problem
I'm working on to make you know you know
to figure out which text came from GPT
and which didn't and he said but but he
was very confused and he said but that's
easy because the stuff that GPT says is
highlighted in green yeah so so so I
think you know I think that this this
approach is kind of like that right
um
okay now one of the simplest things that
you could imagine is uh if you um you
know let's say you know if everything is
going through open AI servers then open
AI could just store a giant database of
everything it generates right or just
put everything in a in a big old hash
table right uh you know encrypt it if we
if we like and then we could allow
people to make queries to that hash
table right so so anytime you have a
text you know you can you can just make
a query and see how much overlap is
there with stuff that has been generated
uh and now you know this this this
doesn't work no uh uh uh naively right
because you might get a match for
because of something that's you know
basically deterministic right like you
know you ask GPT for the Declaration of
Independence right okay you know no no
no surprise that the uh uh uh you know
that now now the Declaration of
Independence is in the database and will
be flagged as having come from there but
uh
um
but you know you could you could deal
with that problem uh you know the bigger
issue is that uh it becomes challenging
to give people a guarantee that their
conversations with GPT will now be kept
private that details of the
conversations cannot leak to anyone else
okay I mean it seems like maybe it's
acceptable because you know you're only
finding out if there is a match but uh
you know I was I was unable to prove a
theorem that I was satisfied with that
would say uh uh you know no no one else
will learn anything about your
conversations uh with GPT by cleverly
exploiting uh queries to this to this
kind of database uh and um you know even
even if you could prove that you know
that you know the it would be very
difficult socially right like people
people might not trust it right as soon
as as soon as you're opening up the
database to queries then you know a
single software bug could uh uh uh you
know a a reveal all of like people's uh
private conversations with with the llm
so uh so so then we come to
discriminator models and this is the
main approach that has been deployed so
far okay so uh this is where you just
treat it as yet another AI problem you
just train some other model to
distinguish AI generated text from Human
generated text and uh so there was an
undergrad at Princeton named Edward Tien
who made a service that does this called
gpt0 and he put it online and I think
within a day his server crashed from
just the number of you know teachers and
professors uh wanting to use this it's
it's back up now you can you can try it
uh openai actually for a while had its
own uh a variant of this called detect
GPT but that was actually taken down
recently and uh the the main problem
that's Arisen with these is just that
they are not accurate enough and in
particular they you know are own to
generate false positives okay they can
say you know I get uh famously they they
even said that you know like a
Shakespeare you know the Bible you know
like these are you know uh these are
suspicious these are possibly AI
generated okay because you know because
yeah our archaic language is you know
pretty far outside of the the the the
the normal data that it sees so not
surprising that it could throw it off
but you know we've we've now already
seen students uh falsely accused of
cheating uh using GPT okay and partly
you know apparently because these
software tools said that yeah
another way so for people like us who
have rented lots of papers in the past
so essentially my writing style is
already available in the form of all the
papers everything so therefore I have
that defense that the style in which I
wrote this article you cannot accuse me
of having plagiarized because the style
of this is close enough to my previous
start yeah I mean I mean you could
always tune a discriminator model on
samples of that person's output right
that probably you know doesn't work for
like an undergrad writing a paper right
where you know they don't have all this
other stuff that that's up but yeah you
you you could you could imagine tuning
you know on on a particular person
yes I mean
take a big
uh yeah I mean I mean you could you know
if you have enough samples then of
course you could try to improve the
model that way yeah
um but you know then again you know how
would you know how would you rule out
the possibility that all of the you know
Umesh simply you know got lazy he fed
all of his samples two GPT and he told
it now write more in my style yes
[Laughter]
so
uh you know I've I've I've tried to give
GPT examples of my blog posts and say
write a blog post in you know my style
just you know refuting this wrong
Quantum Computing paper so I don't have
to do that anymore uh you know I don't
know if I should be disappointed or
relieved that it is not yet able to do
that satisfactorily
um so uh okay so this so This brings me
to the uh the fifth approach and the one
that I'll focus on uh for the rest of
this talk which is watermarking and uh
this means you know sort of slightly
modifying the way that the llm itself
operates in order to insert some sort of
statistical signal into the choice of
words or or tokens that's being
generated uh such that you can detect
that signal later if you know what to
look for okay so um you know it's a it's
a it's a very simple idea although
although it actually surprised some
people that this that this was possible
but hopefully you know after this talk
it won't be surprising it will just be
um like oh yeah of course you could do
that uh so um you know it relates to a
much older idea called steganography
right which is secret writing uh which
you know apparently even in uh thousands
of years ago people were doing right
where you uh you know you write to
document but sort of hidden within it is
some second other message which is the
real one that you're trying to
communicate
um
you know and there is some some
theoretical work you know even about
steganography uh from uh 20 years ago uh
um but you know um I'm I'm typically uh
you know the uh these things are very
non-robust okay so so one basic
requirement from the outset you know
that we have is that if someone takes
GPT output and and if they make at least
some minor modifications to it where you
know I'll leave undefined you know what
we mean by minor modifications that'll
be a big issue later but but uh whatever
we mean by that we should still be able
to detect The Watermark right that
should not make it go away okay so it
can't be some sort of very finely tune
like look at every you know 43rd
character or something like that right
because you know the slightest change
would completely mess that up uh uh but
on the positive side when we're
watermarking a language model we can
take advantage of the fact that we're
not just given a text that we then have
to modify to put a watermark in okay we
have the output of the language model
which are not just tokens but which are
probability distributions over tokens
right so we see we we can see the whole
probability distribution you know the
whole of each token conditional on the
previous ones you know the whole garden
of forking paths right and we can sort
of steer the llm you know through that
through that Garden you know in a way
that that encodes the signal that we
want
so um let me give you know a very brief
history here so you know I had this
moment of Terror you know about what
loms were going to be misused for you
know last summer basically and you know
you're you know now that I'm thinking
about AI safety like you're constantly
asked to prognosticate like how how how
many more years until AGI and what's the
probability of Doom and all these you
know I I have no idea right I I don't
know any of this stuff uh you know my so
far my record I think was that I was
able to correctly say about three months
into the future okay so you know I was
you know you know the the the the the
the the desire the widespread desire for
something like watermarking that you
know became clear as soon as chat GPT
came out okay so I started thinking
about that uh uh before there was chat
gbt and you know I came up with uh uh
what seemed like the most most
reasonable way to do this and then
explained it to people at open Ai and
they told me that I had rediscovered
something from machine learning called
the gumball softmax rule so I said okay
uh so uh anyway I'll show you what it is
and why you why you want this this
particular uh uh rule for doing it but
uh so I I but then you know I proved
some theorems and I realized that the
key quantitative question was how many
tokens will you need in order to get a
reasonable signal right and this will
depend on you know the entropy that
there is in each token so it will you
know but but you'll you know you'll want
some bound you'll want to I said okay
this is you know uh you know I uh you
know I'm I'm uh um mostly in in in in
ignoramus in this area but one thing I
know how to do is like prove an upper or
lower bound on something so okay I can
do that and and uh gave talks about it
and then um I worked with an engineer at
open AI named Hendrick Kirchner and he
wrote a test implementation of this
method and you know seems to seems to
work fine
um uh and then um
you know it's sort of sat around uh you
know it uh uh uh you know the no
decision has been made about deployment
uh uh yet but uh in the meantime what
happened was that uh you know various
academic groups sort of independently
came up with most of the same ideas uh
so um uh there's a group at UMD
um uh Carson Bauer at all and uh Tom
Goldstein and you know so they had a
paper
um which I think was actually like a
best paper award at icml where they they
said uh uh well you know you can modify
the uh um you can insert a watermark by
just taking the probabilities that are
output by a language model and slightly
modifying them like favoring certain
outcomes over others now you know we we
had thought of that as well uh the
problem with that is that it uh it for
all we know it might degrade the quality
the llm's output right because now
you're really messing with the
probability distribution uh and you know
in a way that that's possibly detectable
okay and so you know this this it might
be fine you know you might just do
experiments and find out that it's fine
but you know we wanted kind of a
stronger guarantee than that so um okay
but then um in June of this year uh
there was a paper by uh Miranda Crest
Sam Gunn and uh where's Amir Sam gun is
over there he was uh actually in in
undergrad with me at UT Austin now a
grad student here uh but you know
somehow we uh we keep you know
rediscovering the same thing we should
we should talk more soon so uh and uh
and and they um I would say they they
that they rediscovered you know most of
the the Essential Elements of what I
proposed uh although they did it in a
little bit of a different way rather
than using the gumball softmax scheme
they sort of bullionized the problem so
they reduced to the case where where
your whole language consists of only two
tokens like you have only zeros and ones
and in that case it's it's very very
simple what what what what's the right
thing to do so they they they uh you
know I mean in in practice it might be
you know uh uh you might not want to do
it for reasons of efficiency but that
you know it suffices to prove the point
uh and uh they and then they actually
went further than I did in terms of uh
proving theorems about cryptographic
indistinguishability so they wanted to
really you know even if you can make
multiple queries to the llm they wanted
to say that you know there is no way
that any uh efficient algorithm can
distinguish the results from you know
the unwater marked you know normal llm
output and I was like okay I don't care
that much about hiding it right we're
not making a secret of the fact that
we're watermarking I mostly just care
about can we make a statement that the
quality of the output is not degraded
okay so uh we know which only requires
like looking at a single query
um
but you know so yeah so their their
paper is out and you can you can look at
that and uh and just at this Workshop I
learned about yet another paper uh uh
um which you know says you know has has
another way to do watermarking and uh uh
you know so so so so so
um um my Approach and and and and and
this approach and probably this one also
you would probably you know you would do
it using using pseudo-random functions
right so that's that's the one
ingredient from cryptography that we
really need here and they sort of
suggested well instead of a
pseudo-random function you could use a
one-time pad right and then that has
some advantages and disadvantages I
guess
um so all right so let me uh be a little
bit more formal about what is the
problem that we are trying to solve here
okay and you know the the nice thing
about this is that it you know sort of
we will not have to look at the
internals of how a language model
operates right we will be able to treat
it as a black box and that's that's sort
of why we'll be able to prove an actual
theorem right about about you know what
is about about you know what's the
what's the right thing to do and why
does it work right uh uh you know and
and you know you'll see that we get
something that's you know that's not
fully satisfactory you know it can be
attacked and if you wanted to defeat all
the attacks then you might have to go
inside the model and then we're going to
lose any theoretical control but you
know for now let's stay where where in
the in the zone where we're uh in the in
in the safe space for the theorists okay
so uh so we'll we'll imagine that we're
given you know a a sequence of tokens uh
W1 up to WT minus one and then we have
the output of our of our language model
which you know took as input you know
these tokens as the context or some
subset of them and it output a
probability distribution
um uh which I'll call this pt1 up to ptk
over the TF token okay W sub T the one
that we're we're going to Output next
right now in normal operation of a
language model the next thing you're
going to do is sample from this
distribution okay that's not the only
thing you can do right you know you can
set the temperature parameter right so
sampling from this is what you'll do if
the temperature is one but if you set
the temperature to zero then you're
telling it just output that I that
maximizes PTI right and so then that
makes it deterministic right that's a
that would be a different Choice okay
but uh now we're gonna uh you know we're
at we actually want to do neither of
those okay now what what we're going to
want to do is pick the next token pseudo
randomly okay but in in a way where it
looks like you know the if token is
being sampled with probability piece to
buy so you know no one can tell the
difference but we're also systematically
boosting some sort of score that can be
detected later okay so uh so we'll
imagine in order to do this we'll
imagine that we have a pseudo-random
function okay so uh the pseudorandom
function will take as input a sequence
of let's say C tokens so a c gram uh and
um
and it will produce some output for me
it will be convenient to let the output
be a real number from zero to one okay
so you know the outputs of my pseudor
random function should be
indistinguishable from just uniform real
you know real numbers chosen uniformly
between zero and one
okay and so now we want to choose a TF
token I that looks like it's drawn
according to a d sub T but that actually
you know secretly we want to be favoring
let's say the large values of R sub t i
okay and then in the detection phase
okay so so uh uh the the other part is
that someone hands us a text uh you know
W1 up to WN now we have to decide
whether it was generated by this process
or not okay so we have to decide whether
the watermark is there or not okay and
in the detection phase you know we have
the tokens which means that we can
compute these pseudo-random numbers RTI
okay however we do not have the ptis
okay we don't have the probabilities at
detection time why don't we because we
don't know what prompt might have been
used to generate this text and the
probabilities could depend on the prompt
yeah
excellent question so yeah so so the
pseudo-random function you can imagine
that it's parameterized by some key
right uh you know and and and and this
key will be like the one and yes and in
order to uh do the calculation you will
need that key right you'll need the
secret key and then you you get the
control who has access to the detection
by simply you know who who do you give
that key to right and the choices range
from you could keep it to yourself give
it to no one or you could give it to the
entire world right you could make it
completely public that's another setting
that you can think about or anything in
between those two
giving it only to uh
uh canvas and turnitin.com okay only to
you know use them universities or
journalists or something like that okay
you know I'm I'm saying this because all
of these things are being you know have
been considered
all right what else okay
so all right so now I can just tell you
what the scheme is and it just takes as
you say just uh one line to say it all
right so it turns out that under these
assumptions the right thing to do is
that at each position k for a token you
want to choose that token I that
maximizes uh RTI to the one over PTI
power
okay
so uh you wanna you wanna always
maximize this quantity now this is a
notice this is a deterministic rule
right so if you follow this rule you're
going to get the same com completion
every time in response to the same
prompt now some people might not like
that right they might want more you know
Randomness in their in their output if
you want that you can all you you can
always alternate between you know
applying this scheme and just using the
your llm in normal mode right like you
know you could do one token of one one
token of the other and go back and forth
and then you'll have some Randomness and
you'll also have some Watermark you know
obviously the the strength of the
watermark will be attenuated by uh you
know how how often you want to use it
okay but when you do want a watermark
then then then this is the rule
okay now the intuition for this is easy
to say okay you know the smaller the
probability is for some token I so the
smaller is PTI well the larger will be
this exponent one over PTI okay and that
means that in order for I to have any
chance of being chosen if this exponent
is really high then RTI is going to have
to be really really close to one right
in order for that to be that one to be
the maximum right which is intuitively
unlikely to happen which is exactly what
we wanted right if PTI is close to zero
then I should only be token I should
only be chosen a small fraction of the
time okay that but you know of course
that's that's qualitative you know of
course we we still have something to
prove here
uh now what about in the detection phase
okay in the detection phase turns out
that the uh uh well you know what what
what what what uh I think is the is the
best quantity to look at is the sum over
all the C grams of tokens of uh for each
one log of one over one minus uh uh RTI
okay so uh so basically you know this is
something that as R gets closer and
closer to one then this is diverging
right it's it's going off to Infinity
okay so you know you're trying to you
know you're basically saying when the
rtis are very very large when they're
very close to one then this adds a lot
to our Watermark score right this is a a
tip-off that that maybe maybe our
document uh uh came from this
watermarking process
okay uh and then if if and only if the
sum exceeds some threshold we will say
that GP you know yeah it looks like
there's a watermark there okay we can
set the threshold as we like depending
on you know what probability of a false
positive or a false negative uh we're
willing to tolerate
oh yeah we can calculate them because
each one is a function of uh just the
tokens right
so you know RTI is this F value
okay yeah yeah
for this to work like regardless of uh
which key we use as a pseudorandom
function need to give us like a
sufficiently low score for all human
generated data
um there's no particular requirement to
that of to that effect I mean on you
know normal data it should you know like
like I said it should be
indistinguishable from a function that
just takes any sequence of tokens and
Maps it to a random real number between
zero and one
so what happens if it accidentally gives
you a high score for like human
generated data well you know it it it it
it it could do that right I mean I mean
like of course there's always at least
an exponentially small probability that
that will happen right but you know as
you know and this is one of the
trade-offs with this parameter C right
like like if you want to decrease the
chance that that happens then you should
take C to be larger okay on the other
hand as you take C to be larger then uh
the uh um it takes fewer and fewer edits
in order to destroy the watermark okay
so that's that's the fundamental
trade-off here so you know in our
experiments we took C to B5
but okay
um
okay so what are some of the good
properties of this scheme uh first of
all the computational overhead is
totally reasonable right it's uh you
know it's it's basically you know you're
it's the cost of running the llm in
normal mode plus the rounding hour right
uh uh you know at least at least if you
have you know API access in order to do
this in a reasonable way right where you
don't have to call it over and over like
to get the the probabilities or whatever
so uh you know I mean I mean some
sometimes I've talked to people in
crypto and they've said well you know
you could do this you could do that of
course there will be some polynomial
overhead you know that's paid by the
server you know is that acceptable like
um I can I know they're like well what
if it was a constant Factor like a
thousand and I'm like no and they're
like well what if it's a factor of two
no okay what's it what is acceptable a
factor of one plus Epsilon okay
so uh and and this gets that right
um
okay secondly we get robustness against
local perturbations so uh even if
someone changes some words reorders some
sentences or paragraphs and so forth uh
as long as we preserve a large fraction
of the C grams right that's all that
matters right we're still going to see a
large Watermark score right so so it had
you know and this is why we wanted these
R tis to depend only on C grams because
you know because though those are things
that seem like yeah you know many of
them will be preserved even if you even
if you edit your document
uh and then we have this property of
indistinguishability which says that the
output looks exactly like normal
language model output except to someone
who is able to distinguish uh the
pseudo-random function f from a truly
random function okay now uh uh why why
is that why do we have this
indistinguishability all right well the
key Lemma is this imagine that the rtis
were chosen uniformly from you know the
unit interval okay then the probability
of token I being chosen would always be
exactly PTI okay now uh you know like I
could give this as an exercise at this
point so you know for people to prove
this but the uh yeah it's because you
know uh uh you know in one slide the
reason is that you know the rule that
this choosing the Uh I that maximizes uh
RTI to the one over PTI if I just take
logs that's equivalent to choosing the I
that minimizes 1 over PTI times the log
1 over RTI right I'm just rewriting what
we're what we're doing right well log is
monotone okay but uh uh uh what is this
thing this thing is an exponential
random variable right and it's got a
mean of one over PTI right if I you know
if this is a rant uniform in the unit
interval then this thing is an
exponential random variable it's just a
probability fact okay and it's got this
mean and now we use a key fact from
probability Theory which is that if I've
got two exponential random variables
with means of one over p and one over Q
respectively and I take their minimum
then I get an again an exponential
around the variable with mean of one
over P plus Q okay and that means that I
can just sort of Chunk these things
together right if I have a whole bunch
of different tokens right you know like
like if I'm imagining you know choosing
my token versus choosing any of the K
minus one other tokens I can just reduce
the case that I'm only deciding between
two tokens right and once I'm deciding
between two tokens well then it's just
an integral that you do and
the answer that you know if I had uh two
tokens with probabilities p and Q and I
use that gumbo softmax rule then you
know the the the tokens get chosen with
with probability p and Q respectively
okay but now you know we haven't yet
discussed what is the role of entropy in
all of this so uh here's Here's a
thought experiment suppose that we ask
GPT to list the first hundred prime
numbers right well of course it can do
that but you know how on Earth would you
would remark that right there's no
there's no entropy there unless you
insert some you know some zero spaces or
you know place so you can play some
games with the formatting right there's
there's basically you know there's
there's no way to insert a watermark but
then again we don't really care right
because you know who you know who cares
whether this list of prime numbers came
from GPT or didn't right so you know the
so so we there's only a possibility of
watermarking when GPT itself could have
make could have made multiple choices
right when there is entropy in its
output okay so the number of tokens
needed to get a strong Watermark signal
will depend on the average entropy per
token can conditional on the previous
tokens
as perceived by the language model
itself so uh so let's define this
quantity Alpha which will be just the
expectation over all of the positions of
you know the the Shannon entropy of that
distribution and that's okay and then
I'll think of the number of tokens we
need as a function of this Alpha okay
maybe in real text you know maybe to
think of alpha as something of order one
right but although it could be less than
that it could be you know 0.1 for
example
okay and now we you know we basically
just have you know some integrals to do
right which uh uh you know even even if
I didn't remember how to do these
integrals uh a wolf from alpha remembers
right so uh okay uh so you know you can
say what is the expectation of your
watermark score uh if you have normal
non-water Mark text and what you get is
that if you have n tokens uh then you
just have you know an expectation of n
just like each term in this summon as an
expectation of one when you do the
integral and the variance is also it
yeah very simple what about for
watermark text okay that's a little bit
more interesting because now you get
this integral here
um uh and you do this one and well you
can prove uh a bound on it in any case
depending on as a function of the
entropy of the distribution and what you
get is so here's the average entropy
paper token and so you get basically the
expectation is shifted from from n from
The unwater Marked average it shifted by
an amount that depends on you know the
how much entropy we had in our
distribution and then there's some
constant Factor okay amusingly when you
do the integral you get this pi squared
over six you know which like the the
Basel problem okay and uh uh uh actually
at intermediate stages you get the Euler
macaroni constant and the the uh Euler
diagama function so but all right anyway
that's that's the answer you get uh so
so now we basically just have a standard
statistical discrimination problem okay
we have you know we can think of our
Watermark score as just you know a
normal random variable right but it's a
normal random variable that has one mean
if our document was not watermarked and
it has a different mean if if it was
watermarked okay so so we have these two
overlapping bell curves and the question
is just now you know how large does n
have to be before this difference is
large compared to like square root of it
right you know but so so we need uh the
uh you know the difference in means to
be well you know large compared to our
standard deviation and you know and then
and then and now it's just the standard
statistics problem and the bound you get
is this okay that the number of tokens
that you need in order to see a
watermark signal so let's say you're
you're willing to tolerate a probability
Delta of a misclassification in either
direction okay then the number of tokens
you need scales like one over Alpha
squared where you know Alpha again is
the average entropy per token time and
that just comes from the you know these
variances having to uh and and Times log
one over Delta
and so what this means is we could set
Delta to be let's say one in a thousand
right you want a 99.9 you know chance
that you're right okay this is still
pretty reasonable right this is I mean
you know there's still a question of
what's the constant you know in the
bigger which of course we'll care about
in practice but you know this this this
looks pretty reasonable right
okay so um you know and I should mention
that when we implemented it you know it
looks like you know yeah a few hundred
tokens you know 10
to pay depending on what kind of text it
is and you know how much entropy is is
in there okay a few thousand tokens you
can be extremely confident
uh okay but now you know how could
someone attack this scheme right we have
to now think like cryptographers okay
and there are some obvious attacks you
know as uh once you start thinking about
it uh um you know like for example what
if a student says to GPT uh write my
term paper but in French and then they
put it into Google translate right well
okay that's going to completely remove
any Watermark because you know it's
doesn't doesn't uh survive translation
from from one language to another but
there are even simpler things here's an
attack suggested by Riley Goodside who I
think came up in one of the previous
talks uh he said you know I would just
ask GPT you know write my term paper my
essay on feminism in Shakespeare or
whatever but insert the word pineapple
between each word and the next okay so
you know when you try that with gpt4
here's what you get uh you know it will
do that actually one of the times I
tried this you know within the essay
itself it started say it's talking about
like gosh all of these pineapples are
really interfering with the legibility
of this of this paper so you know so the
student would have to know enough to
take that out right if that occurred but
otherwise they just removed the
pineapples and now they have a document
with a completely different set of C
grams right and so it's completely
different from the thing that was
watermarked okay so how do you defend
against this I mean one thing is you
could just say look you know it's a cat
and mouse game and we accept that and
we'll just try to be a better cat you
know uh like uh you know if someone
makes a front end you know that uses the
API to do these tricks and get in on
Watermark document and the students can
use to cheat well then we'll notice that
that's happening and we'll block
requests from them or you know we'll
have filters that say are you does it
look like you're trying to evade a
watermark okay this would be similar to
what Google does against SEO people
right and has been doing for 20 years
um you know or you could say it's kind
of like you know software piracy right
like someone 40 years ago could have
said well it looks like you know
software piracy is Trivial so let's just
not bother trying to have a software
industry right and like in some sense
that would have been the
cryptographically correct thing to have
said uh you know but but it but it's not
but but it's not what people said right
so you know you could say look look you
know we're just going to try to you know
raise the effort needed to uh uh to
misuse llms and as people develop
countermeasures then we'll try to stay
ahead of them now if you wanted a more
principled solution uh my opinion
is that ultimately what you want is the
sort of Watermark at the semantic level
so you want to sort of Watermark at the
level of the ideas rather than the
particular sequence of tokens needed to
express those ideas uh you know which
would involve going inside of the
language model presumably uh you know
maybe maybe uh moving around the vectors
you know representing uh uh the tokens
um
you know and then you know presumably
you would lose any theoretical guarantee
right but uh you could try such a thing
uh you know the tricky part is that you
need the output to be detectable right
if you know what to look for and you
also need it to not be detectable if you
don't know what to look for okay so you
need both of those things and um I'm not
I'm not uh let me let me Mark this as as
a big uh unsolved research problem yes
yeah
okay well well imagine for example that
uh uh um you know uh uh it was a
um imagine that your language model was
actually Earnest Hemingway okay and you
know he just you know has a certain
style that he writes in right he can't
help but you know right in this style
where people would immediately realize
that it's him and even if you forced him
to put pineapple between each word and
the next you're still you know in
between the pineapples you're still
going to see that it's Hemingway because
that's just the way that he writes right
so you'd be you'd be inserting a signal
I'd sort of at a deeper level of
description
uh now you know of course this conflicts
with the fact that we want llms to be
able to write in all sorts of different
styles right but the hope is that there
are aspects of style that are not easily
noticeable you know unless you know the
exact thing to be looking for
right yeah
yes
yes that would that would I mean I mean
I mean I mean I mean where else would it
be right it has to be somewhere there
but you know can we actually do this I
think it's an empirical question and I'm
not I'm not claiming to have the answer
yeah yeah
I'm not sure if Anderson is is this this
is specific to a particular LL
M yes so well so so so I mean the you
know the the gumbo softmax scheme that I
showed you that's just sort of a wrapper
that you can put on top of any llm you
like
success yes
uh yeah but but but that that's not a
problem because you just need to sort of
get you know make a function call get
from this LOM the list of probabilities
right and then do the you know do do do
do the watermarking right it doesn't
yeah
that's right at the coding time you
don't need the probabilities that's
really important yeah thank you for
pointing out another reason why that's
important right because the llm could
have changed in the meantime yeah
uh ah yes so so that that's coming up in
a couple slides yeah yeah so okay so I'm
almost done but uh the one thing that I
thought about recently was uh uh uh last
week was supposed that we have a long
document and we think that parts of it
are written by GPT and parts are not
right can we actually go further and
pick out which specific Parts came from
you know have the watermark signal okay
so so a good way to think about this is
that you know we we like we look at
these Psalms the sum of the rtis and it
mostly looks like a random Walk Like an
unbiased random walk right but at
certain regions you know we don't know
how many or how long they are this
unbiased random walk gets replaced by a
biased random walk okay and now we want
to pick out what are the likeliest
regions to to to be the biased walk okay
this turns out to be a known problem in
statistics called change Point detection
okay here's a picture by the way if
you're wondering how I got such a nice
picture I just asked GPT to make it for
me this morning okay but
um so you know here here would be the
way that I would formalize it I would
say you know we're kind of you know we
have X1 up to xn or the watermark
signals S Sub I is the sum of X1 up to x
i and then I'm going to each interval
from I to J I'm going to give it a
watermark plausibility score which is
this which is like a starting penalty of
minus L minus some constant and then I
get a credit of SJ minus s i squared
divided by the length of the interval
divided by J minus I okay so this is
this is sort of like how unlikely
according to a turn off bound with this
you know with this uh the score in this
interval B to have occurred by chance
okay and now we just want to maximize
the sum of these scores right and now
this ends up just being a dynamic
programming problem okay it's you know
uh I'll give as a fun algorithms
exercise come up with with a quadratic
time dynamic programming algorithm to
solve that problem right one can do that
uh you know and I wondered if one could
do better so I asked around and Daniel
Kane came up with an end to the three
halves algorithm and uh and and and an
approximation algorithm getting this
this uses um Newton's myth Newton
iterations and convex halls and uh yeah
it looks like a fun problem but anyway
approach Yeah well yeah because because
we can't make the assumption that that
there's an underlying Markov process
right it's not so that we can't assume
that there's a Markov chain that's like
you know moving between watermarked and
unwater marked regions right so like
this you know this you know I think this
is sort of the more principled way to
form to formulate it right I mean like
if I assume that like at each token
there was a one percent chance that this
this you know that we switched to
Watermark text it's like well I've just
baked in the assumption that my student
was probably cheating right it's like no
no I'm not allowed to do that I have to
be hit over the head with overwhelming
evidence that the student was cheating
you see what I'm saying yeah so this
this is why I can't use the viterbi
algorithm right but I can do a different
dynamic programming method
good so all right so what about
deployment so as I said a prototype of
the scheme was implemented by a Hendrick
Kirchner that's him and open AI seems to
work uh why hasn't it been deployed yet
well I can you know without going into
too many details I can go through some
of the questions that have come up okay
will customers Rebel as soon as this is
deployed and will they all simply switch
to a competing language model okay
because they say you know what is this
this is big brother right you know I
don't want I don't want my you know uh
my stuff to be watermarked okay which
leads the next question can all the AI
companies coordinate to do this at the
same time right can anthropic Google
open AI can they somehow or uh reach an
agreement on what to do
um yeah and then there were questions
that I wasn't expecting okay so this was
a really big one that came up you know
are there people who who we we think
should be allowed to use a language
model without having to disclose that to
anyone such as English as a second
language speakers who are using it to
improve their English right like is it
unfair to them if everything that they
they they they they they do will be
watermarked you know I don't know how to
build a watermarking tool that only
works for unsympathetic cases and not
for sympathetic months right okay and
then there's this huge question who gets
access to the detection tool right you
could give everyone access of course
then you're also giving the cheaters
access which then helps them figure out
how to evade it
um
plug it in
um or you know you could you could you
could you could restrict access to the
detection tool to um
uh to to you know certain services that
you think you know have a you know are
really going to be responsible with it
and have a real need for it you know and
then someone has to be in charge of
deciding who gets access to the tool so
those are all questions so let me
summarize I think that we've made some
progress on the problem of how to
Watermark the outputs of large language
models uh without degrading the quality
and this was the part that seemed to
surprise people people seem to you know
have an intuition that there would
inevitably be a trade-off between you
know water marketing and the quality of
the output and actually no there is no
such trade-off okay uh on the other hand
attacks are certainly possible but you
know so or better what are marking
methods uh you know in the limit where
you've got AI on both sides of the
problem you know I think it's very not
uh far from obvious who who who wins uh
this race you know but uh it's a it's a
you know even even if it we're not
practically important it would be
fascinating as a research topic to know
who wins uh you know I think there are
sort of three key challenges for the
future uh so first the conceptual
challenge can we even formally Define
what is the attack model here right what
is the set of
modifications to the document you know
that that we are worried about you know
I've thought about that for a year and I
have not been able to do that to sort of
Define what is the attack model okay I
would love to hear any ideas
uh and then there's a technical
challenge you know can we Watermark at
the more semantic level you know rather
than just this syntactic token by token
stuff that can be played around with by
by a determined adversary and then
finally there's the social challenge can
we coordinate among the different AI
companies to get something like
watermarking deployed all right so
thanks
[Applause]
uh yeah
thanks
but can you compare uh the watermarking
approach uh rid large with uh the the I
forgot what you call the the database
yes from a perspective from the
perspective of usability of privacy of
security just just did it in a few also
is uh I I
um is there a role for something like
this even in a case uh where there's no
entry right I mean I know I know in the
in the case
times or the
Declaration of Independence okay it
doesn't make any sense but my there be
other situations where there is very low
entropy but still we want something like
this okay so your second question a very
low entropy is different from zero
entropy right very low entropy we can
still do something but zero entropy
you're just saying that it is a question
with a right answer right and you know
and then there's a fundamental tension
between saying you want the llm to
produce that right answer and you want
it to be identifiable it's coming from
the lll right because you know if if it
really is the objectively one right
answer then anything else that was right
you will also have produced it
um uh your first question about the the
uh this approach versus the database
approach I mean I I thought about it uh
well you know I think that watermarking
seems clearly better for privacy right
because you you know at detection time
you don't need any information about how
people were using this llm in the past
right you don't even have access to that
all you have is the text that's that's
right in front of you right and as soon
as you expose all the past history of
the llm then it's like you're opening a
can of worms right and maybe maybe
that's okay right maybe you can you know
uh um provide access that is limited
enough that you're not going to
compromise privacy right but then that
is the challenge that you have to come
up with a convincing argument about
um
so
um what about the approaching
perspective that he tells students use
and then I want you to modify
here some general directions of what
position I want you to show me both
now uh your the original and now the
modification
do the modifications yeah
now you've got the bottom or something
here you've got a watermark whether the
original thing ended in the next thing
we're modified foreign
document and the other document
basically yeah that's it it's an
interesting problem I mean I tried to
think about like what you know again
what is the formal definition of what
we're trying to do here right and it's
really really hard to do that because
what is even the definition of academic
cheating right if a student uses a
language model right they just interact
with it they learn some stuff and then
they go off and write their essay by
themselves that seems fine right but you
know where do you draw the line between
that and then like really totally
relying on the language model it doesn't
seem like there is a line it just seems
like a Continuum right and you know the
the best thing I could come up with is
well the student has cheated if they
turn in work that they themselves do not
understand or cannotic cannot explain
how do you test that well there is a
low-tech method you call the student to
your office right and you ask them to
explain what they turned in right you
know it would be nice if you know we
could uh you know say something more
interesting
yeah yes yes
yeah that's right
I'm going to Theory rates or something
right the water Market question seems to
me to be a little bit differently
yeah yeah I agree
yeah
when people looked at watermarking and
Technology missionary uh Community
um one of the things that they would
play around with is whether your marks
could actually encode additional
information right so you could say what
isn't just a detector a one bit which
was produced by but actually you know
encode other stuff yeah sure yeah
trade-off you could totally do that here
right
you could but the information carrying
capacity is limited by the entry how
much room you have to play yes exactly
um
I'm curious if you've sort of thought
about it you know as you move away from
one bit yes right how fast does this
attack yeah start degrading in the
context of what you're seeing so I did
think about it and I could give you a
bell right which is for if you want to
uh put in K bets right the number of uh
uh tokens that you'll need will actually
grow quadratically with k and this and
you know at least at least in this game
with this method right so uh um
uh for yeah that's right that's right
for a given for a given level of
detectability right so uh you know like
I I was saying like Okay I'm I'm
satisfied if we can just put in the one
bit did this come from GPT or not but
you could imagine at the very least
you'd like different water marks for
different language models right or you'd
like to know did this come from gpd3
your gpt4 you know uh you know so you so
you can you can imagine all sorts of
more fine-grained information that you
that you might want to know and yeah and
sure that can be done at all as well you
know with some attenuation of the
strength of the signal depending on how
many bits you want to insert
yeah how do you think about watermarking
only producing it on the what the
producing end what does that mean like
the creators need to prove themselves
that they create themselves
yeah well I mean that's that's sort of
the uh you know the point here that you
know well at least you're trying to rule
out an alternative hypothesis right that
that you know
use keyboard to type in oh you have like
a proof of keyboard well yeah but I mean
I mean I so so I understand that like
some students are resorting to like you
know making screen captures right or
like recording their history in Google
Docs of editing their their assignment
in order to prove that that you know
that something happened there right but
you know that's of course that's not
foolproof either right you could easily
imagine a generative AI that you know
you say produce a plausible Google Docs
history for this document right and then
you know you'll just imagine that
somewhat someone will code that up right
yeah so
output it happens that Google Translate
for one part or for the core part is
also language model yeah you have two
random generators
them can you understand that it's it
also use Google Translate and it also
used sensitivity
um
well
that's a good question so if Google
translate has its own
um you know uh uh uh uh a watermark and
then it would use I mean like I I would
say without without doing anything
additional the answer would be no the
answer would be you would only see the
watermark of the most recent you know
saying it was done right there's no you
know the other thing would just be an
input prompt right which who knows how
it affected the output uh so you know it
would it would be interesting to come up
with what are marking methods that would
compose in the way that you're asking
for
uh yeah
so by putting the sort of place of
watermarking at the decoding time yeah
and if we're closing the possibility of
uh exposing an API that lets people see
the probabilities and do their own
decoding strategies and things like that
um I'm wondering if there's there's any
way to you know some of the exam some of
the other systems you talked about like
Ghostbuster suggests that there's
already kind of a mark in the text that
language models produce is there a way
to lean into that and sort of Watermark
the the style of the model itself or
something if you're willing to take
well this is
abilities out there yeah I mean this is
exactly one of the things that I talked
about right you know could we could we
somehow you know you know uh uh
um change the weights of the model right
in a way that you know such that the
outputs of this model are you know are
just identifiable right like uh you know
I guess like they said about you know
Newton when he solved the brickistic
realm problem like I I recognize the
lion by his claw right can can can we
have an llm with a claw right by which
you know you you recognize whatever it
does right
um and you know you you could you could
even ask for something stronger than
that which is could we have still have
it be you know uh secure even if you
publish the weights of the model right
and you know maybe even people can then
modify the weights and they can't even
figure out how to get rid of The
Watermark by by modifying the weights
that you've given them right you know
you can you can get as greedy as you
would like here
um John
the idea insufficient details so that we
can understand what's going on
right I I aim to please
laughs
last question yeah
um out of curiosity suppose you did have
access to the model itself can you think
of any interesting ways to improve this
scheme if you knew those
still yeah I don't know right because
it's like as soon as you you know try to
go inside of the model right it's like
now you're now you're underwater right
now you can't you know who knows what
what what what monsters are lurking
there right uh you know but I but I
think that that if you want security
against all these clever attacks then
that is ultimately where you where you
want to go
okay